[Musica]
immagino
è sentito marino
c'era un amore strano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
se vuoi sconfiggere il mostro crea
l'inchiostro
ma che cosa persino benvenuti e
bentornati su all'iter stories nuova
avventura io e merlino chi dovremo
affrontare questa volta il biglietto in
questo messaggio era un po strano devo
creare l'inchiostro forse intende lo
slime fatto di inchiostro o uno sly nero
non so quante possibilità quante vite o
in questa challenge ma lo scopriremo
presto
speriamo di aver capito bene qual è
l'obiettivo della challenge ma mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace se
questo video raggiunge i 40 mila mi
piace ci sarà anche ben di nella vita
reale e sarà molto più difficile quindi
lasciate un bel mi piace e se non mi
seguite ancora su instagram andati a
seguirmi il nome anita stories se volete
potrete andare a seguirmi anche su di no
ma ora mettetevi comodi prendete i pop
corn e iniziamo subito lancia perché i
ragazzi dobbiamo andare lì quasi non mi
aiuterà
c'è quindi il teatrino che dite mi fido
ad aprirlo voci sarà ben di là dietro
io sono troppo curiosa quindi la sils
ottonello ha sposato la ci fosse
qualcosa di più spaventoso da dietro
invece abbiamo successo la cosa nello
spazio che fortuna mi sembra che sia
stato troppo facile che i ragazzi siamo
a buon punto ciotola e spatola ma dalla
colla o l'inchiostro non so cosa
intendesse band con quel messaggio e
bicarbonato e soluzione per reati
ora proviamo andare nell'altra parte
della casa ma questa forse prima non era
chiusa
forse è passato quando proviamo ad
aprirla anche se non so se una pur idea
tu che ne pensi berlino berlino mi
sembra che voglia entrare conosciuto
un pochino la storia se la soluzione per
lenti innesca la vedete io avevo trovato
anche la soluzione per lei chissà se
berlino abbiamo preso la soluzione per
lenti in berlino ma abbiamo perso una
vita non so quante altre vite o forse
due forse tre
avete visto ben diremo sbrigarci qualche
20 e dentro casa sarà molto complicato
trovare gli altri due ingredienti che
andiamo o no
verdini meglio non passare vado allora
coralli lo vedete
e ancora poi se n'è andato proviamo
castori di qualche parte devo andare
allora non c'è niente berlino aiutami tu
chi mi da più parti secondarie dove
possono essere gli altri impiegati che
sono ma vuoi metterti a dormire adesso
sentito
prendilo mattino premio berlino non c'è
nessuno
ma la porta è nuovamente chiusa ma
questa volta nel mondo di qua cento le
scale
proviamo a scendere le scale che tu
possa fare sesso da parte se scompare
quali è andato via
proviamo a scendere restare capite spero
bene re di tebe una trappola
non importa io vado lo stesso a
prenderlo
ma sbaglio o quello con eventi ma una
sua sagoma di cartone
[Musica]
io sono riuscita a prendere il
bicarbonato e ho scoperto che vendi a
usando un trucchetto una tecnica proprio
come nel videogioco compare su cartonato
ma non è realmente lui è solo per
spaventarmi farmi allontanare quindi ora
dovrò stare attenta a riconoscere il
vero dandy anche perché manca solo la
colla o l'inchiostro anche se non ha
idea di dove possa essere secondo voi
dove potrebbe essere come sempre
l'ultimo ingrediente da trovare sempre
il più difficile quindi magari fuori in
giardino
anche se non mi sembra che ha ben di
piazza la luce del sole
sicuramente sarà al buio mi è venuta
un'idea cerchiamo in tutti i posti al
buio perché probabilmente lui si
nasconde nei posti al buio lui piace
d'inchiostro e la carta potrei guardare
tipo vicino alla stampante non so
secondo voi con noi il vero ben di poi
il cartonato mio paura di te belli
[Musica]
ho perso un'altra possibilità non era il
cartonato ma era ben di reale ora penso
di avere solamente un'altra vita
quindi se vendi vince un'altra volta
avrò perso il gioco se invece vinco io
ben di scomparirà quindi dobbiamo stare
supera attente adesso mi è venuta
un'idea per l'ultimo ingrediente
ora andiamo al piano di sotto vicino
alla stampante per più come
l'impressione che vendi voglio stare
vicino all'inchiostro quindi andiamo al
piano di sotto
porto tutti gli ingredienti che ho già
trovato con me perché nel caso che
vendesse ali e io trovi l'ultimo
ingrediente dovrò creare l'inchiostro il
primo possibile e non avrò il tempo di
risalire su quindi porto sotto con me
[Musica]
appoggiato su tiri ingredienti questo
tavolino
ora entriamo nello studio dove c'è la
stampa anche quelli in senso qui
[Applauso]
si fossero salvate
mi chiamo se sì cosa ti ho sentito
cosa qua dentro una stampante
forse qui richiudiamo che qualcosa qua
si misero punto andiamo subito a creare
[Applauso]
marino non ti avvicinare svegliamo
serious man questo stranissimo con la
nera si intendeva questa per inchiostro
marino allontanasi possiamo mettere
questa colla inchiostro stranissimo nera
a liberata che strada sembra davvero
inchiostro
scoliamo speriamo che si attivi subito
ragazzi tre autobus raimo guardate
sembra realmente inchiostro quindi penso
che l'associazione all'indovinello sia
questa crea d'inchiostro per un mandare
via il mostro per sconfiggere il mostro
il eccolo il vostro bene spero che
pulsione gruppi
ecco l'inchiostro benni
sì funzionato ragazzi l'inchiostro ha
sconfitto vendi abbiamo risolto
l'indovinello è risolta la salle
lasciate un mi piace se volete rivedere
vendi a 40 mila mi piace
vendi tornerà ma nella vita reale e
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete altre
challenge slime ora mi lascio qua 4
castellini su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione
ciao